he is the head coach of Notre Dame
football and that's your that's your
team like right yes come on
he is Brian Kelly back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach everybody
healthy and safe in your world yeah
thanks for asking this you know one of
those deals where we're getting at that
point where they're not going to be
healthy my teenagers if they keep
driving me grow at that point where
please yeah I go back and forth there
what I know where it went because I've
got an eleven nine and six at home and
I'm like knock on wood we're healthy but
we're going crazy and then some of my
friends are like try having teenagers
who want to get the car keys you know oh
my god yeah
that's what I'm doing you dig oh wow
gasps places dad it took me 28 dollars
to fill it up I'm like you had no idea
what about the ordering they're entering
into the reality film this time where
everything kind of slows down I know
they start to look at Wow things
actually cost money and yeah you have to
go get a job and work in this day and
age were you point out like things kind
of slowed down but it does seem that
sometimes a day feels like a year and
enough like a year's worth of of
movement or activity can be boiled down
into a day so that's kind of where I'd
like to start with you right now
coach is August 29th there's a game that
you're supposed to play against Navy and
Ireland and where do things stand right
now do you think about your playing
season well I think we're going to play
I don't have the definitive you know you
know 100% but you know obviously things
are turning that way we're moving in
that direction we want to play in the
fall I think the you know all the look
at the end of the day those decisions
are gonna be made by you know our
president our Board of Trustees not the
football coach at Notre Dame
so let's get that straight but you know
we're moving in that direction we're
preparing for those those eventualities
so I think from that perspective I can
say that we are prepared and we know
that there's going to be challenges
there's probably going to be some
setbacks as well and as long as we're
all aware of what those are and how to
deal with them I think I think we're
ready to to play football in the fall
well I look I just had a conversation
with Dave Roberts of the Los Angeles
Dodgers the manager of the LA Dodgers
and I've had conversations like this on
this show and you know it's it's always
I don't want the coaches or managers to
be put in the position of where we're
all expecting you to come up with a
vaccine you know what I mean like and
that you're all now experts in public
health but you know it is it is a
situation that's constantly changing I
mean what what do you tell your your
kids who I'm sure you're you're zooming
with or what-have-you
right now right so that's that's the
most difficult thing as we're planning
on you know no salad bars and you know
you know spacing in the locker room and
the weight room and some of these really
important issues so you can in fact
avoid a hot spot or you know the
potential of you know what the worst
case scenario could be riches and that
is you start and then you have to shut
down the players just they want to know
dates and times they they want to be in
a position where they could put on the
calendar hey what's the day the problem
is we can't give them that because
everything is staged in terms of the
states and the universities they want to
wait as long as they can because they
want to get better testing they want to
get better traces they want to get you
know where are we going to contine and
those things take more time and so we're
in this position where as committing and
we're beating on a day-to-day basis
we're trying to put together protocols
and brands for it but on the other hand
I'm trying to talk to my players every
day and I like coach what do you got for
don't things
and you know I get to the point where
you just it's it I know it's frustrating
for them but they know that we're doing
all the planning necessary because
here's here's where it's a little
different rich than dears task right we
have to over communicate with the
parents cuz look uh if it's my kid I'm
not putting them on a plane to South
Bend Indiana look nobody drives to our
campus we have very few kids within
three hours of our campus you're putting
your son on a plane to Notre Dame I
better know exactly what's in place for
my son when he gets there that he's not
going to get sick and so we we have to
do a really good job of putting this
together so we can over communicate with
the parents as well so Brian Kelly here
on the Rich Eisen show hoping our mommy
prime but you what do you tell the
parents I mean what do you having in
place like testing tracing I mean again
yeah it's not as if layout exactly we
have to lay out exactly what we're doing
are we testing daily are we doing
anybody a thing are we going once a week
are we putting them in pods where you
know they stay in those pods and they're
not going to be disrupted from those
areas so there's there's a lot of that
there's a lot of layers here rich that
that are really new to me
that you know I'm kind of sitting back
listening and trying to find out as a
football coach for 30 years as a head
coach what's realistic what can we do I
know you were talking to Dave Roberts I
was on a call with some Major League
Baseball they're talking about changing
the ball every pitch I mean so they're
talking about not using the clubhouse
that the old days right you know you
come dressed
pop the hood take your bat out and let's
go into play so there's a lot of moving
pieces here that we're trying to get
ahead around and find out what's
realistic to be able just so that's the
information that we got to find out
whether we're going to relay that
information back to the parents or not
and how close are you to having that
protocol lock down we're better we're
better than where we were maybe even two
weeks ago where we have some we have a
document that's getting closer and
closer because we're getting more
it seems as though we're getting closer
to figuring out what kind of capacity
that we'll have for testing you know
those are the things that really
unfortunately have been holding us up a
little bit because we needed to know
what kind of testing capacity that we
would have in place Brian Kelly Notre
Dame Fighting Irish head football coach
here on the Rich Eisen show a few more
minutes left with with with you coach
and then your you you might be in the
most unique position of all because as
usual your schedule is kind of like a
United Nations you know where you've got
a Mac team you got five ACC you got
pac-12 you got Big Ten so you know for
your schedule to go off you could say
we're ready we've got the protocols our
kids are gonna be safe as possible but
then you've got another conference
saying yeah we're just not gonna do it
and then you're scheduled that's totally
blows so what were how do you handle
that
I mean what's what's the deal on that
right I mean obviously you know we're
looking at you know can some of these
conferences do a plus one game you know
will will Wisconsin play us in Lambeau
Field you know we'll see which we are
collateral partners for six games will
they give us our six games
I'm sure what they say will come if the
check is the ink is dry you know I think
that that's going to happen you know
maybe is going to be a game whether it's
played you know in Ireland or I mean
they're certainly gonna play so my point
being is that will find will find enough
games it seems it's pretty clear that
things are going to stay within their
conference at least that's what appears
to be the case right now right I think
we're in a position but I can
confidently say that work for you get
enough games to be in the discussion for
even whatever whatever the postseason
look like that we'll have enough games
but you feel because again I mean the
number
variables you and I just discussed in in
the last six seven minutes I'll use the
phrase I use with Dave Roberts my head
is spinning and yeah so but you still
ultimately feel why do you why are you
are you just glass half-full or why do
you feel like you're gonna have a blank
season here well because I didn't Aversa
t want to have one I mean the Cal State
University system pulled the plug on it
because they did not for some reason
feel as though they wanted to you put
people on their campuses and we are
going to have to make that decision as
well and again I want to be purple I am
NOT speaking for University Board of
Trustees but you know we will have to
make a decision that we feel comfortable
that we can bring people on campus and
in in doing so we're going to play
football there are students on our
campus we're playing football and we are
taking the painstaking step necessary to
ensure the safety of our players and
support staff and those people around
them that if in fact we do take the
steps to open up our campus and whatever
capacity that looks like which right now
we're going to be able to play football
good luck on that man I'm sir I mean for
sure I I know that sounded flippant but
I mean it I mean every word of it no
Sarah cuts again you're you're you're
gonna have to you've got a lot of
partners that you got to figure out or
you know obviously from parents faculty
board of trustees athletic director and
then when I mean partners I'm talking
about all these schools that you you've
got to either visit or go to they've got
to say yeah we're gonna do it for you to
be able to play all those games so I say
best of luck and let's stay in touch
and we'll have a conversation about it
always always thank you you bet this
Brian Kelly Notre Dame football